así es es correcto tuve la oportunidad
de estar con él
verlo tan feliz porque en verdad estaba
muy feliz estaba yo lo vi muy bien de
salud y el tono de ánimo
donde tuve la suerte de cantar con él en
un pequeño concierto y con su piano y me
llamó para que cantara con él yo creo
que fui el artista el último artista o
cantante que él acompañó con su piano en
vivo en estos para mí es un honor un
privilegio realmente de seguro que así
fue bueno no sólo fue esta en esta
última vez sino que usted se había
cantado con manzanero cuéntenos que le
dejaron todas esas experiencias no sólo
no profesional más allá de esto
lo que pasa es que yo conozco al maestro
manzanero desde que yo tenía 16 años
entonces conviviendo con mucho con él
tanto lo personal y después como
profesionalmente tuve la oportunidad de
hacer muchas giras por españa tuve la
oportunidad de grabar un suponer tuvo la
oportunidad de grabar un dueto con él en
el disco que hizo serán los grammy el
reto número uno que hizo para para
warner yo tuve la oportunidad de cantar
contigo aprendí con él eso y muchas
otras cosas que tuve la oportunidad de
estar exponiendo
carlos nos quedan muy poquitos segundos
no menos de un minuto pero si tuviera
que contar ustedes las nuevas
generaciones quien fue armando manzanero
armando manzanero fue el último baluarte
el último evaluar desde el romanticismo
de méxico para el mundo sin lugar a
dudas yo creo que el mandamás ya no se
va a quedar en las generaciones futuras
durante mucho tiempo primeramente dios
da lo que da muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 ha sido un placer
recordar a armando manzanero